[Music]
so what are the best and worst animated
godzilla versions and flicks there have
been quite a number of references cameos
even entire episodes about the g-man in
other shows there are also animated
movies and series about godzilla as well
so let's rank them all just the animated
godzilla's that is
let's showcase each one of them and then
rank them from worst to best in the end
so let's get to it
let's start with hannah barbera godzilla
seen in 1978 the anime cartoon series
the hannah barbera godzilla unlike the
incarnations of godzilla featured in
touhou's film series is entirely green
in color his dorsal fins are unlike
those of any other godzilla in that they
begin at the top of his head and are
more triangular in shape compared to the
maple leaf shaped blades
he also has very long human-like hands
and has a new power
in that he can shoot laser beams from
his eyes he is the second tallest
godzilla standing at 122 meters or 400
feet tall
the one thing that we can't get over in
this version is the bat road that he has
kind of sounds
unlike any other godzilla
second let's look at the godzilla series
this was zilla jr that followed the
tristar movie godzilla of 1998 along
with his baron they were both heavily
mutated iguanas not dinosaurs not
extinct life forms super species or
underwater organisms the eggs are
heavily irradiated by nuclear testings
in the pacific the sense of the parent
did fall down on the sun in this one the
design was not really a welcoming sight
as just like the original tri-star
godzilla he had a theropod dinosaur
posture with triangular dorsal plated
and a tail that hangs midair for balance
however a plus point for him is that he
has the atomic breath power but then
again he has weakness that a normal
gosler would not like sensitivity to
electricity and can be killed with
enough firepower from conventional
weaponry
thirdly let's look at the anime godzilla
from the trilogy the anime godzilla
earth was an aok
look to the eyes it didn't have the
oversimplified designs of the cartoon
hannah barbera version
nor did it have the hated zilla's design
but it was slow and cumbersome the one
thing that dave did good was the
mysterious origin story behind him and
that he had eradicated humanity as well
as all the other kaiju and aliens from
planet earth he changed the biology of
the planet itself in a sense that
everything now was a part of him and he
is planet earth itself in a way this
version was the biggest ever standing at
more than 300 meters or 1000 feet tall
and he had a wide array of awesome
powers
so next let's now see
godzilla from singular point this
godzilla although new was not really
received with much warmth from the
g-man's community he had four forms that
he successfully evolved into
as the 2021 series progresses the
aquatic first form a quarterless then
amphibious firm amphibia a
dinosaur-shaped terrestris and lastly a
charcoal black form the ultima form
this godzilla seemed to be too
far-fetched and the origin story kinda
sucks as he was a product of
trans-dimensional elements called the
archetype this godzilla was slow and
seemed to be less of a threat and more
of a global nuisance sort to say this
but the horror element that is attached
to godzilla in the recent years was
replaced with a truckload of sci-fi
fantasy and a lot of undefined
unrealistic physics
next let's look at shinchan godzilla the
cameo this one was seen in the show
crayon chinchon and it was an episode
called shinjan vs shin godzilla it is
the 901st episode of the series it aired
on nippon tv on july 22nd 2016.
the entire episode was centered around
godzilla emerging from the ocean and
attacking tokyo and how the protagonist
shin chan rescues the city the animated
godzilla in this one was shin godzilla
in his fourth form but not a live action
version rather a cartoon it was the same
as the movie shin godzilla version but
lacked the pink atomic breath and
instead had a blue one anyway this one
was a fun cameo and nothing much can be
criticized which means it's pretty good
so let's look at the shinkansen godzilla
cameo another lengthy cameo of the g-man
in animated form came in the show
shinkansen 10k robo shinkalion the movie
something something future alpha x
pretty long name
snow godzilla was that form and it is a
giant creature who inhabits in another
dimension and so when a huge amount of
glowing particles are released in the
show snow godzilla was affected by the
particles and got sent to the world
where the anime takes place he has a
height of shin godzilla but the design
is a mix between shin and both the showa
and heisei versions but with a skin that
has a snowy texture and blue glowing
dorsal blades overall it was a good look
for him and his powers are beyond any
makers from that show could stand up to
next we see the hero academy godzilla
cameo in the series hero academy
the godzilla that was seen was the
heisei godzilla design from the touhou's
1991 movie godzilla vs king ghidorah but
then he possesses a very dragon like
appearance with a very long tail and
clawed paws for hands he is covered in
dark grey scales and appears to be of
quite a white build like buff most
prominently around his legs and torso
his hero costume consists of a white
coat with a high collar ripped to match
its standard design and a pair of baggy
white pants this godzilla version was a
celebrity and a movie star in that
universe it was a good cameo but i wish
i had good things to say about this
version
and lastly simpsons godzilla cameo this
one is hilarious this cameo occurred on
the episode number 226 and the name of
the episode is 30 minutes over tokyo the
simpsons family's flight home is briefly
interrupted by a monster attack on tokyo
featuring godzilla and other japanese
film monsters which is gamera rodan and
mothra godzilla grabbed the plane kind
of shook it in the air and then while
letting it go
godzilla attempted to throw a tang at
their departing plane only for it to
miss by a long shot causing godzilla to
humorously kick down a tree in
frustration
godzilla was navy blue in color with
light greyish blue dorsal plates he
looked good overall in this one
considering the fact that it's the
simpsons
there were also other cameos of him in
the simpsons one where homer is godzilla
and fights gamera
another where marge transforms into a
bridezilla and fights king rong which
was king kong as homer and even one one
where godzilla was signing autographs to
fans in comic-con
so yes worst to best mind you this would
be our ranking yours can be different
let's see out of the eight entries
number eight would be hero academy
godzilla on the seventh spot the next
spot we will put in zilla the series you
know zilla was a pretty bad design
the next is hana barbara godzilla for
its simplicity on number five we have
the singular point which uh was kinda
sucky since we can't really understand
how it came to be
then we see shin-chan's shin godzilla
now on the third spot we will put the
simpsons for their funny iterations of
the g-man then on number 2 we have the
anime trilogy godzilla earth and lastly
we think snow godzilla is the best
animated form of godzilla but that's our
pick you can arrange your own list down
in the comments
anyway with that we come to the end of
our video so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam